allora io parlerò di sharing economy
devo stare attenta a non cadere dalla
pedana perché un brutto vizio
parlerò di sharing economy e del suo
impatto sul sul mondo del lavoro nella
farofa non iniziando a parlare a
raccontare di qualche storia di quattro
storie quattro esperienze che si trovano
tranquillamente sui portali che vengono
definiti appunto di sharing economy
la prima è quella di paolo polo affitta
la sua casa attraverso alberghi a bienne
be è una piattaforma che mette
direttamente in contatto le persone che
hanno una casa o una stampa esempio da
affittare e che invece ricerca per brevi
periodi o lo dicevo affetta la sua casa
sui navigli sua bienne be per 90 euro al
giorno
90 euro al giorno noi abbiamo visto che
tra gennaio febbraio quindi in periodo i
mesi in cui milano non ha nessun evento
particolare paolo affittato la sua casa
per circa 10 15 giorni al mese
facendo un rapido calcolo quindi paolo
ha guadagnato da questa attività 1.000
1.500 euro al giorno al mese magari
questa è altra storia è la storia di
mary sedile le melissa nel e organizzano
cene a sorpresa tra sconosciuti a casa
propria sono cene e che stanno andando
benissimo tanto che ci vuole quasi due
mesi per riuscire ad andare a mangiare a
casa di lele e di melissa ogni ogni
cielo né organizzare un paio al mese
sono
otto persone e non di più accettano solo
otto persone e ogni persona deve pagare
tra i 30 e 40 euro
anche qui facendo un rapido calcolo
melissa e lele guadagnano da questa
attività 650 euro al mese partito tutto
ho sbagliato qualcosa
aiuto ok invece lucia vende vestiti che
fatti a mano infatti da lei su etsy
eh sì è un portale che mette
direttamente in contatto piccoli
artigiani e persone che desiderano
acquistare i loro prodotti
lucia ha venduto dal 2007 anno in cui ha
aperto il suo negozio sua ex su etsy
5.451 capi facendo una media sono più o
meno 770 capi al giorno al mese all'anno
questa sera sbaglia tutto per una media
di 50 euro a capo ci sono dei capi che
lei vende per 10 euro e dei cavi che
vende per 300 euro per cui ho fatto una
media decisamente al ribasso facendo un
rapido calcolo melis lucia vende ha
guadagnato 38 mila euro all'anno da
questa attività perché infine matteo
matteo invece il lavoro a milano e il
fine settimana ritorna a treviso dalla
famiglia prima utilizzava il treno e
spendeva più o meno 80 euro per andare e
tornare oggi invece utilizza bla bla car
che è un servizio che mette direttamente
in contatto chi ha un posto in macchina
vuoto e chi ha invece desiderio di
necessità di utilizzare quel posto per
fare quella tratta quindi mette
direttamente in contatto autisti e
passeggeri con bla bla caro matteo per
andare a tori a treviso e tornare
indietro ci mette spende più o meno 30
euro quindi risparmia su ogni tratta 50
euro per
al mese sono 200 euro risparmiate al
mese perché io ho raccontato queste
storie questa storia hanno qualche cosa
in comune e hanno cioè il fatto che
tutti e quattro personaggi che abbiamo
visti monetizza non cioè guadagnano da
dei beni che sfruttano appieno nel caso
di melissa ed ii.dd lucia in realtà sono
delle competenze che loro sfruttano
appieno nel caso invece di paolo e di
matteo sono invece proprio dei beni
questo è stato reso possibile ha reso
possibile da tutta una serie di
piattaforme e che esse stanno veramente
esplodendo in giro in giro per il mondo
che rientrano in quella che viene
definita la sharing economy la scena
indie coniugano economia della
condivisione o della collaborazione è un
insieme di servizi che mette
direttamente in contatto attraverso
piattaforme digitali e le persone
persone che da un lato hanno qualche
cosa da offrire e dall'altro persone che
invece cercano proprio quella cosa lì
sono avviene quindi una nazione che ha
spesso in alcuni casi è mediata dal
denaro invece no altri casi c'è solo
scambio di beni senza alcun alcun
compenso
questi servizi sono già in mezzo a noi
citava diceva prima alessandro appunto
di share italy che è l'evento il primo
evento sull'economia collaborativa che
c'è stato a milano il 29 novembre scorso
acer italy c'è stata l'università
cattolica presentato questa ricerca
nella quale si afferma che sono già in
italia 250 piattaforme collaborative 250
piattaforme che sono cresciute
soprattutto negli ultimi anni cioè dal
finire del 2001 del 2012
oggi che continuano a crescere che ne
continuano a a me ne continuano ad
arrivare proprio sul sul portale che io
seguo e dove collezionò queste
piattaforme
anche se poi non nascondo che ce ne sono
già alcune che iniziano invece a
chiudere se da noi però è ancora un
fenomeno assolutamente giovane è ancora
tutto sommato poco conosciuto in america
e nel resto d'europa se ne sta già se ne
sta già
se ne sta parlando molto dal 2010 che in
generale si parla di sharing economy da
quando cioè rogers e racz il box one
hanno scritto questo libro che si chiama
fosse ormai inizio se che rappresenta un
po la bibbia del della sharing economy o
consumo collaborativo come lo hanno
chiamato da allora i numeri sono
lievitati nel senso che nel 2010 era
ancora un fenomeno di nicchia un po come
da noi in italia ma oggi si parla già di
un mercato che ha un valore di 553
miliardi di dollari negli usa di 22,4
miliardi di sterline in uk pari più o
meno a 1,3 per cento del pil che
l'incidenza che ha ancora in in uk
ma che cos'è questa sharing con lasciare
aiuto in sostanza che cosa dice dice che
dentro di noi e dentro le nostre case
abbiamo già tutto quel che ci serve per
guadagnare o risparmiare qualche cosa
per fare bene all'ambiente per sentirci
un po meno soli perché condividendo e
scambiando noi abbiamo l'opportunità
quindi come dicevo prima di risparmiare
o di guadagnare abbiamo l'opportunità di
far bene all'ambiente perché produciamo
meno e abbiamo l'opportunità di creare
nuove situazioni nuove relazioni ed
instaurare nuove relazioni sociali che
cos'è che si condivide si condivide
davvero di tutto per facilità io ho
diviso in queste quattro in queste
quattro raggruppamenti si condivide cosa
e tempo competenza e denaro per esempio
secondo video come dicevo cose quindi
riguardando il mondo dell'auto noi
sappiamo che l'auto in realtà non la
usiamo solo per
l'otto per cento del suo tempo il 92 per
cento del suo tempo l'auto rimane ferma
a casa in america ma stanno arrivando da
noi
prestissimo verranno aperti anche in
italia ci sono due servizi che invece
aiutano a sfruttare appieno l'auto in
servizio e quello della rai di sharing
peer to peer
cioè il servizio come lift che mette
direttamente in contatto passeggeri e
autisti un po come bla bla carmax della
balla carrà funziona sulle lunghe tratte
servizi come lift invece funzionano in
città quindi se io da qui a stasera
posso tornare a casa in trama piuttosto
che magari avere all asp e mettermi
direttamente in contatto con una persona
che sta passando di qui mi tira su e
andiamo a casa insieme
l'altra opportunità invece arriverà ai
suoi servizi come relais rights che sono
car sharing peer to peer
invece di lasciare la macchina ferma
sotto casa c'è l'opportunità di
prestarlo a vicino perché non poter
monetizzare da quello che noi in fondo
abbiamo e abbiamo sotto casa
questi due servizi e nel giro di un anno
mi sentirete parlare anche qui in italia
su tasche rabito invece tas tramite un
servizio che mette direttamente in
contatto persone che non hanno tempo con
chi invece ne ha
sono nel sud askrabic è possibile fare
piccoli lavoretti come ad esempio
assemblare i mobili dell'ikea che pare
sia quello che va più che va per la
maggiore
piuttosto che consegnare qualcosa
piuttosto che invece fare fare la spesa
ce n'è uno che mi è particolarmente che
trovo particolarmente carino c'è una
persona che ha affidato ad un rabbit tra
di loro si chiamano così affidato la
pole al il lavoro di andare a fare il
regalo per la suocera cioè assegnato a
un altro la possibilità di fare un
lavoro
il regalo per la sua terza suocera su
sky c'è invece si condividono competenze
fuschi che ora si parte dal presupposto
che noi tutti sappiamo fare qualche cosa
allora perché non mi mettono a
disposizione degli altri su strisce era
quindi sì con sti c era si possono
organizzare corsi di ogni di ogni tipo
cioè non si troverà mai strisciare il
corso di yoga piuttosto che di html ma
se troveranno piccoli corsi per piccole
competenze specifiche come per esempio
corsi di fare la torta migliore è la
torta di mele più buona del mondo
piuttosto di come viaggiare intorno al
mondo prima di avere 65 anni
infine kickstarter pistard era il più
grande servizio di crowd funding al
mondo è possibile inserire sulla
piattaforma un progetto e chiedere a
persone di finanziarie o con piccoli
prestiti e complice che con piccoli
finanziamenti che cosa sta emergendo
stanno agendo una nuova figura il
microimprenditore così viene chiamato
cioè colui che grazie a questi servizi
prendendo e maneggiando dicevamo questi
servizio può arrivare ad avere
un'entrata a a finire diciamo a
completare il proprio reddito e ad avere
un'entrata un'entrata superiore il
microimprenditore in genere può essere
uno start upper può essere un è in
generale uno start upper è un
ma scusate microimprenditore sono mamme
start upper sono freelancer e sono tutti
coloro che in generale utilizzano queste
queste questi servizi per arrivare a
fine mese ma anche per riuscire a fare
qualche cosa che altrimenti non
potrebbero fare come ad esempio un
viaggio piuttosto che avere del tempo
per utilizzare con gli amici per stare
con gli amici e con la propria famiglia
si chiama microimprenditore si chiama
proprio imprenditore perché in realtà è
creativo perché deve continuamente
adattarsi e continuamente inventarsi un
nuovo il nuovo lavoro flessibile perché
deve adattarsi e rispondere alle
esigenze del mercato e gesto proprio
tempo perché lui che decide come e
quando fare il lavoro sono tre
caratteristiche se ci pensate bene sono
quelle che il lavoro a tempo fisso non
ci annuncia mai ci hanno tolto perché
durante un chi ha un lavoro a tempo
fisso non può sicuramente all'interno
del suo proprio posto di lavoro essere
creativo c'è difficilmente riesce a
essere creativo difficilmente riesce a
essere flessibile e molto difficilmente
riesce a gestire il proprio tempo quello
che però il lavoro se il lavoro ci ha
tolto flessibilità creatività e gestione
del proprio tempo
ciò però dato sicurezza e protezione
cosa che invece ovviamente dice
ovviamente che cosa che invece questi
servizi non ci danno che cosa succede
infatti se un artista come quelle di
liste piuttosto che non sa non lavori
decide di lavorare 10 ore al giorno come
assicurare che chi affitta la propria
casa paghi le tasse regolarmente come
esseri sicuri che il cibo offerto dalle
case sia sicuro e controllato
ci vogliono nuove regole per fare in
modo questi servizi permettono infatti
di monetizzare permettono da quello che
noi già abbiamo
ma bisogna creare delle nuove
regole affinché si favoriscano questi
servizi affinché si riesca a fare in
modo che questo denaro e riesco a
entrare effettivamente nelle tasche
delle persone ma contemporaneamente si
tutelino quella se quelle quelle regole
che abbiamo messo anni e anni per
ottenere che adesso devono essere devono
essere in qualche maniera valorizzate e
e e controllate grazie mille